Ángela Costa Rica Está De Fiesta primera
Victoria para los chicos en esta Copa
Mundial de Qatar 2022 lo hicieron aquí
en el estadio akman vinali con ese
triunfo 1 a 0 contra Japón los chicos
que venían con muchas dudas y casi que
contra las cuerdas después de ese Debut
con esa derrota 7-0 contra España se
enfrentaban a Japón una selección que
venía de dar la campanada al ganar a
Alemania pero los chicos se llevaron hoy
aquí los tres puntos una primera parte
muy luchada con poco fútbol ante una
Japón que realizó cinco cambios sobre su
11 inicial no estuvo tanque fuso cubo ni
tampoco de ingreso Y el que se estuvo de
ingreso fue duan uno de los autores de
los goles contra los germanos con Costa
Rica o apenas dos cambios en la titular
para la segunda parte de los nipones
demostraron ese fútbol que vimos contra
alemanes y el fútbol ofensivo incisivo
con las bandas y fue precisamente en el
mejor momento de los nipones cuando
llegó el gol de keiser fuller de
centrocampistas del herediano que le dio
a los chicos esta Victoria único disparo
a puerta para el equipo Luis Fernando
Suárez que está vivo y más que nunca
aquí en esta copa mundo aquí en un
estadio en donde los chicos eran minoría
les venimos contando que había una
fuerte presencia de las elecciones de la
hinchada de las elecciones asiáticas Hoy
no fue la excepción hoy dominaban Los
japoneses apoyando a los suyos viendo
esta derrota que podemos decir
sorpresiva después de lo que ocurrió
después de lo que ocurrió en la primera
jornada de este grupo e Juan por este
mismo grupo hoy tenemos más tarde un
duelo de los gigantes que se enfrentan
en momentos muy distintos hablemos de
eso
España y Alemania se miden para cerrar
esta segunda fecha de este grupo en el
estadio al 20 en la jornada estelar de
ese partido y con esa victoria de Costa
Rica lo que pasa es que da igual el
resultado que haya entre a España y
Alemania nada se va a decidir de manera
matemática en este grupo sino hasta la
tercera jornada y que se juega el
próximo parte el próximo jueves con
España se especula con que Rodri no va a
ser titular en defensa con Alemania las
dudas siguen siendo en donde entonces en
torno así le doy también podrá ser
inicialista para este partido si España
gana a Alemania eso sí virtualmente
estará casi que en octavos de final por
esa diferencia de cuál es precisamente
por esa Victoria 7 a 0 contra Alemania
la última fecha de ese grupo será
entonces en los partidos entre España y
Japón y de Alemania contra Costa Rica
hoy también como adelantaba adelantabas
antes Ángela también hay actividad por
el grupo F se enfrentan también Bélgica
contra Marruecos y Croacia se mide
también contra